[Music]
greetings from berlin and welcome from
the city's jewish museum my name is
karen helmstead
1700 years since the first documented
evidence of jewish life in germany it's
an anniversary and a chance to celebrate
jewish culture history and everyday life
and that's what we'd like to talk about
tonight in our discussion the third
generation on the move
we'll hear from younger jews about what
makes them tick
how do they experience judaism and
jewish identity here in europe
and how are they pushing to break with
stereotypes and write their own
narratives
[Music]
these are just some
of the questions
that we hope to ask this evening
and these are my guests
dimitrijko pittman is to my left and
he's a writer journalist and so-called
jewish quota refugee from ukraine he's
the author of two books that draw from
that experience recently became a german
citizen and says he shares
responsibility for the country as such
along with his family and friends their
collective foes and whether he likes it
or not
a war malcolm
shai terry is an israeli-born
mezzo-soprano she came to germany in
2018 and is currently doing a masters in
voice at the university at the mainz
school of music she says living in
germany has made her more conscious of
her jewish heritage and more observant
of her traditions welcome
deborah feldman is a writer whose
best-selling memoirs unorthodox and
exodus recount her escape from the
ultra-orthodox
satmar community in williamsburg new
york she now lives here in berlin and
has a german passport and says i'm
german and i refuse to be introduced as
anything else
welcome to you deborah
hetti bag over here on my right hail's
from the netherlands and has over three
decades of experience in culture
management last year she took over as
the director of the jewish museum here
in berlin so she's effectively actually
the real host and says that she only
gives a platform to voices that reject
violence and exclusion and approach
others with respect
and finally also in our audience today
is levi israel offer filger he's the
author of nisht ona manakipa which
translates as not without mykippa and
he's here to
speak to us and bring in the perspective
of a third generation religious
conservative
thanks very much to all of you for
joining us now it's very interesting all
of our panelists on stage here are born
outside of germany all came to germany
for very different reasons you're all
working in creative capacities and yet
all have very very different
perspectives on uh
jewish life in this country shy terry
i'm wondering i just spoke about the
third generation on the move
do you see it that way is that an
accurate description
i think so i think the
for me as third generation here to live
in germany was something that i actually
dream about all of my life
because uh my grandparents were living
in frankfurt for almost 20 years
so i basically grew up with traveling to
germany coming back to israel and my
very first
baby step were actually here in
frankfurt
and
and for me to come to germany was
something that i wanted to do and now
i'm feeling that
this is also my delegation
and as ambassador
um
i think this is something that we as the
young generation as this third
generation for holocaust survivors this
is something that we want to
accomplish here with our lives
being israeli being jewish being also a
woman
and
yeah this is something i'm very proud of
and i think that
we should keep doing that
thank you and we're very glad that
you're that you're here with us this
evening dimitri kapelman you were eight
years old when you came to germany uh
from the ukraine how much of
a shake-up are you seeing amongst the
young jews of your generation i do sense
a strong self-confidence
among
the younger generation and
this is something i really enjoy
from what i hear from from jewish people
i know and who i perform in front of and
read to
their strong will
and a strong
sense of urgency
to do so another writer here on the
stage but with a very different story
deborah feldman your path has
consistently been one of rebellion uh as
a jewish woman as a feminist how strong
is your sense of community with your
cohorts here in germany that you're not
alone in this quest for
self-determination
very strong i would say it's the first
place where i felt any sense of real
community as opposed to like
imposed or performed community
um i
am continually
bowled over and
deeply gratified
by
the diverse experiences and perspectives
on jewish life that i have encountered
in berlin
there are many things that i
experienced here for the first time
for example the fact that so many young
jewish people who only have patrilineal
jewish heritage and are therefore not
considered to be
you know 100 traditionally jewish
exactly the fact that here they um fight
for recognition and for acceptance
that's something that i was only
introduced to here it wasn't an issue i
was faced with before and i think that's
just one of many examples of young
people
basically announcing that
they are prepared to completely change
the meaning of
what jewish is and that very little can
get in their way
thank you very much heti berg
we've just heard this is this a kind of
a modern expression of of young judaism
in berlin after just over a year here
how are you perceiving the discourse the
ideas the activities of the young
generation uh in germany
well it was certainly one of the things
that attracted me to come to berlin and
to
lead this wonderful house
that there are so many people here
the young generation
maybe also already the generation before
that are really
very consciously
trying to define for themselves what it
means to be
jewish
and
yeah so all these many voices all these
different perspectives
is also something that we that we show
here in the jewish museum berlin which i
think is also very important to show
because most people have
don't have
such
nuanced idea about what jews are so this
whole dynamic way of jewish life
i think that is one of the yeah one of
the very interesting things here in
germany berlin especially and great to
show here in the museum
thank you very much particularly here in
berlin and you mentioned many voices
we'd like to hear some other voices and
so we spoke to two young filmmakers who
were making waves at the recent jewish
film festival
in berlin two filmmakers who represent
the jewish younger generation in germany
meet to exchange ideas
they're both here visiting the renowned
jewish film festival berlin brandenburg
cryet helped put together this year's
program
the lineup shows how young jewish men
and women see themselves and how they
want to be seen
wildly funny yet rousing reckoning with
stereotypes
when you say you're jewish in germany
and out yourself as a jew
it's like the world around you turns
black and white people can only think of
the holocaust
in germany when folks talk about jewish
life they're talking about dead jewish
life not about life
but at some point enough's enough
isn't one of those conciliatory
characters
and of course it's also a privilege for
him to be aggressive and angry
that's something dimas parents likely
couldn't have afforded to be when they
came to germany
there's a new generation of jews who are
confident who want to shape the
conversation and um they don't want to
be forced into these old roles
and shahron khan is one of them the
franco-israeli director was born in
germany and returned in 2007.
her documentary displaced is an attempt
to clarify her relationship to her
birthplace and process her family's
history
to break their silence about the
holocaust
foreign
but the third generation is in a very
different situation the holocaust is
further in the past but having that
distance is difficult
even though i was born in germany
i often feel the need to forget where i
am
in order to feel free
naturally i'm collective
of course collective traumas still have
an influence and of course that impacts
us
and yet we live here we have german
friends and good times and some bad
times too
we're here
let's
just two of many who view jewish life
differently
who are redefining it and making it
their mark
shy terry is there still too much focus
on the past on the ugly things the
holocaust um
when we're talking about jews in germany
what do you encounter
for me i think that um we're
as the young generation
we don't concentrate a lot on the past
especially among the musicians like this
is the
surroundings and the colic that i have
like mostly
and
i really think that when we are coming
to this point that we are talking about
this topic
it's the atmosphere is getting
completely different
then everybody is getting more serious
everybody is getting
more into their
thoughts and
and i think that most of my friends here
are actually non-jewish and the history
we're trying somehow to live in the past
and really to
leave the presence as it is and that is
so beautiful and so
great as
we are all friends and trying to live
really with great harmony
deborah feldman how is it for you i'd
i'd like to see how you perceive jewish
life in germany compared to what you
know in america and i'm wondering to
what extent is jewish identity um some
something that is sometimes decided for
you
well i will say that my experiences in
american society um
ranged from
absolute disinterest to rejection
i felt like there was no room for my
identity that america was requiring me
to be absorbed into the melting pot and
nobody wanted to know about where i came
from and it was one of the reasons why i
think i felt so strongly driven to to
write my story because i was i wanted to
be heard i wanted to be understood i
wanted to be able to say to people oh i
grew up hasidic in brooklyn and i wanted
that to mean something that people would
be able to recognize what that meant and
know who i was as a result and when i
came to germany i think i was i was
quite surprised
by the intense and passionate interest
that was shown me from all segments of
society and even the ones i think we
wouldn't expect it from i mean i think i
met palestinians for the first time in
berlin and i was taught to be so afraid
of that encounter and these encounters
turned out to be incredibly human and
peaceful because we were alone with each
other and it wasn't the entire world
staring at us and projecting their
politics onto us
and so i feel like berlin is a safe
space for people to
to connect with each other on an
individual level and i feel like on you
know on the basis of these individual
relationships there's so much you can
build but like shai you know i find that
many of my friends are not of jewish
background of course i have um i have
friendships with jewish people but
certainly the friendships i have with
jewish people are what i would call you
know unconventional and these are
unconventional jews dimitri capital man
you're nodding
i'm going to continue to not i'm just
thinking as a jew from the forum soviet
union the demon that we saw in the film
has similarities to some degree with
edema from your latest novel so let's
learn a little bit more about your story
dimitri capital man
born in kiev his family moved to germany
in 1994
he writes about people caught between
two worlds
[Music]
what exactly it means for my
non-religious father to be a jew remains
indiscernible to me to this day
in his family judaism was barely visible
yet omnipresent his books are laced with
his own special brand of humor funny yet
sad too
and i've written a second book
it has cats
it has corruption
it has cats
did i say that already
and it's about my mother yes it's about
her too
his novels are a declaration of love to
his parents dmitry capital man has
managed to do what they couldn't feel at
home in germany
my parents were on the way to israel
they had their stuff shipped already
then they had a change of heart
and one day i asked my father like 20 20
years later maybe
why why germany of all places because
obviously
you're not trusting this place you're
not trusting this country
there is no building on an individual
level not not from what you give out not
what you get
and he told me because of you
because since your mother is not jewish
you would have always have been a second
class
jewish citizen there
and that's quite a burden
it's
one thing to know that you somehow
shaped the destiny of your parents your
family that much
and then also in this particular case
that
your parents probably would have done
way
better there
and still you know i wasn't really
involved in
becoming
a child
exactly you were busy right
better stuff to do
so
this in itself
is so sad
that it's funny again is that still true
in or is that true in israel that
someone with a jewish father and not the
jewish mother would be considered a
second-class citizen is this modern view
of things um
changing there or not no not at all it
is absolutely like this and this is
something that
i'm very
not proud of and for me it makes me very
very disappointed and not proud of it i
don't know how to call it even
yes absolutely i want you thanks
i'll keep it brief first of all when i'm
in israel i'm not even second class
jewish i'm just russian
and um
the second thing since i mentioned it
about being jewish from the fatherly
side
i suffered from it
deeply
i had complexes i thought this is this
is a general failure of
me
but these days
i think this is a gift
this is god's way
of
keeping me away from
dogmatism
god's way
yeah because until now i had no idea
he's not religious i'm making you a jew
but i make it especially tough for you
to be one
[Laughter]
you grew up in the state of saxony and
arriving there in the 90s you were
immediately subject to
anti-semitic threats attacks harassment
what goes through your mind when you see
the anti-anti-semitic attacks on the
rise in germany today
well i'm depressed i see how we're not
evolving as as human beings and as
society we're not
it's still monkey brain
when i see this we are evolving
obviously but
not all of us at the same pace
there's still a lot of work to do
because of the upward trend in
anti-semitic crimes in germany the
berlin-based rapper ben zalomo says that
this anniversary that we're actually
using as the hook for this talk here
this evening this anniversary year is no
cause at all for celebration and his
song de duskka which means grandfather
expresses just how torn
he feels living here
israeli-born rapper ben zalomo says out
loud what many jews in germany are
thinking
anti-semitism is still being downplayed
even if politicians have begun to react
and provide means to address the problem
some feel that's not enough
the anger and impatience is completely
justified and understandable because for
years actually decades germany slept
through the fight against anti-semitism
they closed their eyes to it and only
woke up a few years back
[Music]
studies show anti-semitism is deeply
rooted in about 15 to 20 percent of the
german population
and it's taking new forms
at protests against corona measures
anti-semitic conspiracy theories are
being spread and the holocaust is being
trivialized
[Music]
and at anti-israel demonstrations jews
have been subject to pure hate
like here in gezenkirchen
that's the really fundamental change in
the recent past those with anti-semitic
views are more willing to articulate
them in public and are increasingly
prepared to resort to violence
in germany jewish life is increasingly
under threat
the numbers prove it
in 2020 anti-semitic hate crimes rose by
almost 16 compared to the year before
and that feeling of being threatened
weighs heavily on jews says marina
chavinski founder of ophec a counseling
center for anti-semitic violence and
discrimination in germany
it doesn't automatically mean every
person has had direct personal
experiences
but there's a considered caution
or a lasting sense of potential danger
a danger that can also turn into terror
like during the attack on the synagogue
in hala in 2019
two people were killed though this door
saved the lives of many more
[Applause]
talia feldman was in the synagogue that
day
an american who lives in hamburg she
dealt with the trauma through her art
she's collected data and audio from
racist acts of violence during the last
40 years
recognizing that behind that data
our people and our hearts
feldman's sound installation reveals the
structures behind right-wing terror in
germany
her work is about remembering and
mourning
about hearing and listening but above
all it asks
if we can't
recognize the continuities
how are we going to stop them from
happening in the future
[Music]
how are we going to stop this from
happening some very sobering lyrics also
from ben salomo
a fellow israeli and that song was
dedicated to the victims of anti-semitic
and racist attacks uh here in germany
and hala and in hanau chai terry
you have some thoughts i think after
this piece yeah my very last concert
before corona
was in the synagogue in mainz
and it was 2019 and it was really
um a few months after the attack in hale
and
usually we have
always the police that are guarding
the synagogue but there there were much
more because of this concert from the
jewish community
and because they knew that are going to
be a lot of people in this concert and
that was the very first time for me
that i felt insecure before i went on
stage to sing you felt afraid i felt
really afraid for me as an artist just
this feeling it was something that i
never experienced and i re i really wish
that i would
never experience again never experience
it again hetibag um obviously the
officers and the the constant security
are no are no
unusual thing for you working here in
the jewish museum germany's culture of
remembrance these
as they call it here with regard to the
crimes of of uh nazi germany
has been widely admired in the past and
and admired um internationally as well
why is it failing to grasp the actual
the really present reality uh for jews
today and and and failing to protect
them
i think it's not only um a problem that
is in in germany it's also
something that's very hard to
to define exactly this is also something
that we try to
to present to to the people that come
here in the museum that
it's it's uh it's hard to define what is
anti-semitism exactly where does it
start what can you do
uh against it um
in in the netherlands also every
synagogue is being
guarded their security i mean i'm
i'm totally used to that
i'm afraid
i think it will
always be there in a way and it will
it's not just in this group or in that
group it's in the middle of society
it has
it takes different forms and
the only thing you can do is is to yeah
to try to make people aware of this
stereotyping and at a very early age and
i don't think it's like okay germany did
a really good job so how is it possible
this anti-semitism has always been there
after the war straight after the war so
it's not something like
oh this is suddenly happening again and
i think that's also
important to to realize
and yet there is a rise that that that
you have noticed as well uh dimitri
capital man i'm going to go over here
because as i mentioned levy uh israel
ufafirge is following here from the
audience and i have to come down and
because of corona i have to stand one
and a half meters away from you thank
you very much
uh
mr overfigure born 1988 in west germany
and you're a student of rabbinical
studies and author of the book as i
mentioned earlier
niched ona my kippah not without my
kippanova kippah which you're wearing
here today is
obviously a very important symbol of
belonging for you and yet as we've seen
with recent attacks just this summer
even it very clearly makes you a target
standing up uh and making sure that this
kind of thing doesn't happen but what
are your what's your response uh to the
to the rising anti-semitism in germany
at the moment
well my response is um not to back down
as you mentioned the kippah is my symbol
of jewish expression is very dear to me
and i um and i'm quite stubborn in uh
being visible i really um
like and love my jewish identity and um
i am
ready to um
bear the consequences that might happen
um to me but i must say i was very lucky
really
just lucky in the past years
that nothing
worse than
some
bruises happened to me
i find it to be very very important to
keep on being visible in this country
because i think
um
that just being private and being
invisible just does more harm than good
to us
as a teacher and a religious leader you
were just recently at the jewish uh
international school you're educating so
to speak the fourth generation of of
jews uh how do you prepare them for this
kind of of everyday onslaught for for
this this
for how they have to sort of comport
themselves in the world
well i guess is all jewish educators do
these days um we try to um do everything
to to give our students and to help them
develop on their own a good
jewish
identity and self-expression and good
jewish self-worth
we can't save
from everything that is going on but we
can give them the tools to
wreak to it and to be
resilient and
the means of
how to be careful when you're visible
you don't have to be too adventurous
and you also need to get a sense of
where you're
secure or where it's too dangerous to be
visible or outspoken
um and you also need the
the right tools to
get other people's attention if
necessary you're studying to be a rabbi
at the new center of jewish theology in
potsdam and that brings together a
liberal both liberal and conservative
theologies i'm just wondering how
helpful will this be to have judaism
more firmly anchored and perhaps
recognized in in germany uh as
recognized as the christian religion oh
hopefully it will do other religions
hopefully it will do a lot i mean rabbis
are very good multiplicators um if we
let them be um and if we have some
rabbis who are um also well-versed and
um
uh and well-educated
um i think we have a great
responsibility
in our non-jewish environment especially
as rabbis or soon to be hopefully rabbis
to to engage in every kind of
inter-religious and intercultural
concept i think it's key
to get to know each other thank you very
much levi israel of
for those insights
[Applause]
spoke about visibility and uh not
backing down deborah feldman you fled a
very visible um ultra religious
community did really the unthinkable
from the point of view of your family
and your community chose to
move to germany
um
berlin earn your own money do all of
these things that were not were not
acceptable
any misgivings for having
with with the situation at the moment
that that
how do you feel you can contribute to
um
what hetibag was talking about in terms
of
broadening uh
broadening perspectives and and not
allowing this anti-semitic
wave to
take over
it is important to me to show people
that judaism is not a monolith
and that even within monolithic
communities there is a lot of dissent
and a lot of diversity
and
i'll be honest and say
that
before people like me i don't want to
say just before me but but my generation
has a much higher number of
ex-orthodox people than have previously
existed in the jewish world and i think
before we showed up
and we made a fuss
people didn't really wrestle with the
idea of orthodoxy within the jewish
world and jews didn't wrestle with it
and non-jews didn't either
and
it is not just of social importance but
of political importance because in in
the day and age we live in religion has
a dramatic impact on politics and
therefore on our society you know on a
global scale
and we see it
happening and it is only going to get
worse and so
what i want to contribute is essentially
the other side of the coin um
it's uh you know the dangers of
retreating too far into identity the
dangers of forgetting our common
humanness
do you ever feel fear in berlin
um
i don't think so i feel
i'll be honest on this count as well i
have felt unsafe in my life but mostly
as a woman and not as a jewish person
and sometimes in berlin i also feel
unsafe as a woman
i have witnessed many anti-semitic
incidents but i have witnessed many of
them outside of germany
what i appreciate very much about this
country is the fact that it is a central
topic of discussion we talk about
anti-semitism we talk about what causes
it where it comes from
how we can
prevent it from happening how we can
address it once it's happened
we keep it visible in the public sphere
it is a cultural priority in this
country that is unique
that is not common across the board in
my experience
berlin obviously a place where you feel
safe it provided very much a safe space
for you to continue writing your story
and deborah feldman's story of course is
one that many people will be familiar
with let's look a bit more closely
deborah feldman was born in new york she
came to berlin in 2014 after fleeing
from the subjugation she experienced in
her ultra-orthodox jewish community
in her best-selling memoir unorthodox
and in a film she tells her story
i was to have intercourse with someone i
didn't know whether i wanted to or not
so i had sex it was extremely painful i
cried
and the following week i found out i was
pregnant
deborah feldman has settled in of all
places a country reviled by her hasidic
jewish community
in 2020 her book was adapted into an
emmy award-winning mini-series
unorthodox a glimpse into a little-known
world
a literary survival story
and a blow for freedom
[Music]
freedom and and liberation you've uh
said i read a quote of yours that you
said the german identity is linked to
guilt shame struggle with the past and
these residual traumas people many
people might wonder how that um can be
liberating
well i guess maybe it's just liberating
for me right i mean maybe because i come
from a culture so deeply influenced by
survivor's guilt
and
by
the inability to recover from trauma
maybe
it was only like that for me personally
that i came here and i realized well
everybody's like that here
just one of millions
and i felt
i felt inordinately relieved
like i finally wasn't alone with this
feeling that people understood
what it was like to live like that and
even if it was from a different
perspective it's
we're all haunted in the end in the same
way because this generation
it's not about who our grandparents were
it's about who we are now and what world
we want to build
language is a very big part of your new
identity and you're actually even
writing your first novel in german
how does that feel
really
good
um
i'm
struggling actually even um these days
to to write in english because i feel so
emotionally alienated from english it
was never in my language i had to learn
it to get by he grew up was the only
yiddish exactly it was the only language
available to me if i wanted to get out
and live another life and so
i i took it on right i made it my own
but it was never my home
shy terry your thoughts on on on
delving into your new german identity
and being here embracing this country
yeah so as you said i moved here almost
three years ago
and
i decided to learn german as fast as i
can
and um
to
to be more like integrated with my
friends
um but also i was i i found it really
really interesting that
all the people that i met here was
related to me as i'm
shy terry that came from israel
and as more as an israeli as a jewish
girl
and for me it was very very interesting
to see how the people are reacting to
these two different things
to be israeli and to be jewish and i was
also very very grateful to have
great people around me that wanted to
know my
religion my tradition and my culture and
was asking me so many things about it
and people wanted to learn some new
words in hebrew and
wanted to come to my home to celebrate
shabbat with me and as a jewish israeli
you're one of many young israelis who
have
chosen to leave israel and move to
germany let's hear a bit more about shy
terry
[Music]
born in northern israel she studied
classical music in tel aviv soon after
she began performing at official events
in israel and toured the us
she sang for the israeli military
serving as a soldier for two years
[Music]
along with classical music she also
sings hebrew songs that's important to
her
[Music]
but it's not just with her singing that
shy terry transcends boundaries
[Music]
since 2018 she's been living in germany
making a dream come true
for now she plans to stay in her new
homeland
[Music]
you study classical music but as we saw
there you also have a passion for hebrew
songs you work a lot together with the
pianist adibar what kind of resonance do
you get from uh from your audiences from
german audiences but also from the
jewish communities here that you sing
too
um
so
i can sing a whole concert in
five different languages and then my
very last anchor will be some very
little song in hebrew and the people
will be remembering only that
even though i made some crazy
arias and pirouettes with my voice but
they say that
they
remembering only this one so it's an
idea of feeling at home we're going to
come back to that i'd like to come over
to hetty berg because you've also got a
very a very european perspective uh here
coming from the netherlands um you're
someone who has always
asked questions as you say asked many
questions as the second generation the
second generation here on our panel and
sought to understand the bigger picture
of jewish heritage
petty bag at the opening of the jewish
museum's berlin's new core exhibition a
year ago
born in the hague bag is an active
member of the liberal jewish community
she studied dance art theatre studies
and management her talent for bringing
people together is something that's
urgently needed in berlin
at the jewish museum in particular
since childhood hetteberg has regularly
visited her family in israel tradition
means a lot to her
her advice to young visitors to the
jewish museum
be open to other opinions
and above all
learn to think for yourself
how easy is it to
encourage
people to think for themselves of some
of these big issues
that you have to
present here i think what what you can
strive for is
that when people come
into
this museum
they come with certain notions about
what it is to be jewish
uh what jewish
what jewish means
um and
uh also for jews themselves that can
also be like that
experience that you know you're there
that you show different perspectives and
that at least you put something next to
that what they already thought
and maybe that will move something in
them moving their in their thinking in
their opinion or maybe in their feeling
definitely and and and a huge gift for
the city the jewish museum has been a
welcoming space for learning and
dialogue and that in fact for exactly 20
years
it hit berlin like a bolt of lightning
back in 2001.
from above the jewish museum berlin
resembles a shattered star of david
a building that attracts attention and
leaves plenty of room for interpretation
20 years ago the museum's opening was
marked with a state ceremony
it was a sign of change
german jewish history would no longer
only be told in the context of the showa
the museum would present jewish life in
germany through the centuries
polish-born israeli-american architect
daniel liebuskind managed to create a
space that integrates the historical
with the contemporary
the building's voids create a sense of
openness while simultaneously pointing
out what is missing
the victims of the holocaust
it is architecture in service of the
past and the present
europe's largest jewish museum presents
one thousand seven hundred years of
german jewish history in a playful
interactive way
the new permanent exhibition which
director hedy beak opened last year also
focuses on aspects of daily jewish life
what is kosher food
what happens on the sabbath
but space is also devoted to the dark
side of jewish history a history of
exclusion and expulsion
impressively documented in hundreds of
laws
discrimination and anti-semitism existed
long before the shawa
alongside its core exhibition the museum
mounts changing exhibits on sometimes
controversial topics
like the uneasy cohabitation between
jews christians and palestinians in
jerusalem
and there are shows on contemporary
jewish art
currently one is devoted to israeli yael
bartana who uses images to question
historical narratives about jewish
history
the museum is not averse to
provocation i think the museum is alive
as you walk through it as you see the
exhibitions
contemporary exhibitions new
installation i think it's fantastic i
think that's the idea of a museum a
museum is a dynamic institution it's not
just a static you know box with
something inside of it it reflects
changing realities
[Music]
one of these is right across the street
the newly opened children's museum anoha
this noah's ark is open to all children
regardless of religion and culture
the jewish museum berlin a meeting place
for all generations
[Music]
your plans for the future do you see
yourself actually staying in in germany
and much of your family your
grandparents actually went back to
israel will you be staying here
i didn't know what germany has to for me
to offer from studies from job from
um
experience
but i also
met the love of my life here and we got
engaged a few months ago
so um i guess i will be staying here for
a little bit more congratulations thank
you very much
and um
yeah but in general i feel like um as we
all speaking about home i feel
um home is where
you feel your best version of yourself
yeah and home is where the people you
love are surrounding you
so i have my home of course in israel
with all of my family and all of my
friends but i created my very own home
here
dimitri capitelman you traveled to
israel with your father to better
understand your jewish identity
uh ukraine was your lost homeland
germany was you're not really yet
homeland did it help going to israel
well is it
yes it did
and it
surely helped me to uh
grow as a person
and as a writer but
this whole thing i don't know so it's
not it's not an option for you
um it's just not in the cart but that's
okay i i have different cards
it took you many years to
take on german citizenship now you have
the nationality
is can can germany still become a
homeland for you going back to what
deborah said
um
we we're trying to figure out now who we
are and i'm as well of course i am
however and it's it is still related to
the past because the change the links
are broken at some point it's hard to
find that it's hard to
to to reconnect
who you are if you don't know where you
came from
so
with that being said and keeping your
question in mind yes i feel at home as a
german
jewish
russian writer
that's that's what i have to offer but
but but here's the thing this is this is
how we often perceive that
this unclear belonging is minus i did
myself but it's not it's an enrichment
and we should stop demanding
things to fit
that almost automatically they're not
they can't deborah feldman
because you've adopted the german
language we use the word in german
obviously haimat
uh for homeland this feeling of homeland
i i think i read somewhere uh that you
said it was possible to never arrive is
a feeling of haimats or homeland is it
is it necessary can germany
fit that bill for you one day i i think
i think what i said was it's possible
to be at home in the experience of not
having a home like to just maybe get
really really accustomed to it and feel
comfortable there
um for many people that's the only
option um
i have you know i've gotten into
arguments with with you know
conservative leaning thinkers you know
who are in my generation my age group
who who argue that jaime is extremely
important that it's what germans say
identity right it builds identity
without haimat without home we don't
have identity and you know i would say
yes i'm sure it's important for some
identities um i but i think there are
still identities that do not require a
fixed sense of home
the way that jaimat connotates and um
however what we really say you know
that's my opinion when we say hi matt is
um
a sense of
social rootedness right a sense of
social connection and belonging and
berlin has always been
both famous and notorious for offering
this to people um immediately without
making them work for it and
just as easily and quickly letting them
go if they want to do so so in that
sense
certainly i have
set down roots in the very thin
sandy soil of berlin
as as have many of us
and sandy soils yes definitely
scraping underground but
always
feels good when you fall it's not as
hard as certain surfaces thank you very
much to all of my guests it is time to
wrap up we're obviously looking at an
incredible diversity of experience of
jewish life on this stage it is going
forward and dealing with issues of the
past and constantly grappling and
actively shaping new conversations let's
make sure we keep listening to them
thanks to all my guests and thanks very
much to our audience and uh until we
meet again all the best
[Music]
thank you very much
you